let's go to the next caller from the 303
area code who's calling today from 303
hi david can you hear me yes i can who's
this
hi so i just go by t um i'm originally
from colorado currently living in
massachusetts on the north shore how are
you doing
i'm doing well and you said like the
letter t is the name you go by
yes how did you get that name i'm
curious
oh just a shortening of my name to be
honest i'm trying to
uh anonymize my political opinion
um uh because i find that i've actually
suffered some uh uh career setbacks by
virtue of sharing
um my politics online really
are your politics left or right
um i'd say uh progressive left uh
libertarian
and and and in what industry or field
can you say generally have you been um
hurt due to those beliefs uh so
i've been in uh software in uh product
management
in software being progressive hurt you
that's interesting that's not i wouldn't
necessarily assume that
uh well you know it's part of the sort
of corporate infrastructure of the world
yeah i gotcha okay well what's on your
mind today
so um yeah so i guess by way of sort of
quick exposition to my main question um
have you heard of the concept of
federal decentralization federal
decentralization
i mean maybe maybe but not by that name
what what specifically do you mean by it
yeah so fair enough so there are several
types of federal
government or government
decentralization but the sort that most
interests me
is a political and regional one
which in practice would mean basically
reducing federal government over
authority over policy making and
delegating it to a
smaller number of regional subsets of
the federation that are more aligned in
terms of
like politics and culture and history
sure um so so i've basically i've been
working on this project and i've
identified
five such regions and the closest
analogy
uh those probably by no means perfect
would be the coven 19 regional
coordination packs among states
which hasn't really come up much lately
but uh
i'd apply that to sort of the political
system as a whole
so what would the regions be you've got
you've got new england plus new york new
jersey right that would be one region
sort of the northeast
so uh yeah so essentially it'd be like
the boston washington
uh corridor and probably extending a
little further to uh northern north
carolina which is by far the most
uh the most uh like liberal
for lack of better terminology um you
know
part of north carolina um the second
would be
uh the the west coast uh but including
some inland territory the
um front range uh of the rocky mountains
and through uh northern new mexico
um and uh southern uh arizona would be
the second one
um the third would be basically the
center
of the country essentially um the fourth
would be
essentially what we call kind of most
the midwest um but including upstate new
york uh vermont
and uh northern new hampshire and
maine and the fifth would be uh the
fifth would be the um
basically the southeast uh but it's
basically been
um sort of lacking for
representation in federal government due
to state boundaries
okay i mean i guess i could take issue
with a couple things there number one
that west coast region is including some
pretty dramatically different areas
you've got the ultra liberal parts of
the country
and also extremely rural conservative
parts the way you've done it i also
would you know the idea of also dividing
states where part of vermont is in one
region part of vermont
is in another maybe it's a little
complicated but okay i understand i
understand the framework so now i think
we can get to the question piece
yeah so really i was mostly just
interested in you know when this time
that we live in where we're
sort of have very different approaches
um it's a very polarized world
uh very polarized country i should say
um where we have these very different
approaches to kobit 19 to the racial
justice
protests and sort of the proper response
to them um i'm just curious if you think
this this
model as a whole whether or not we agree
on boundaries you know is an open
question but sort of the approach as a
whole um i'm just interested to hear
kind of your perspective
well listen i i'm not like a secession
type
guy where i think the country should
necessarily be split i think that the
level of chaos that that would cause and
bring up a whole new bunch of
immigration issues so i'm not like a big
divide up the country into different
countries
type of guy however particularly during
coronavirus
yeah i mean listen new england plus new
york and new jersey
are running coronavirus responds one way
what's happening in the southeast is
completely different i mean it has
nothing to do with it
whatsoever and the us is so big that you
know really these regions are like
european countries in many ways
sometimes geographically
sometimes in terms of population so i do
think that
there are significant enough cultural
differences
differences in business um you know the
primary businesses of different areas
that
it may it intuitively makes sense that
we should be thinking of the us
more regionally now the thing is we
already have 50 states so you could say
we already do that
states rights 50 states 50 each state
can do what's right for them
but that doesn't what i think that
ignores is that there are certainly
groups of states that are very similar
in a lot of ways the states with
you know the best health and education
systems often are close together
um so so i like this idea of thinking
about
some problems more regionally without
saying we've got to secede or divide up
the country
i think the devil is in the details but
i'm very open to that
that's awesome to hear yeah no i think
uh just just one point of clarification
so i'm actually not in favor of you know
secession
oh yeah yeah yeah no i wasn't saying i
was saying it more so people don't think
i'm saying
split the country up in this way yeah
yeah i mean that that's kind of why i
formulated under this federal
decentralization model but
um if i might uh just plug quickly so
i've started a
project on twitter called the decent fed
project
um at decent fed proj um if you or
any of your listeners want to check it
out um it's just you know it's
like i say i come from a software
background so i'm kind of a systems
guy so i'm interested in kind of new
approaches to governance that might
you know improve the situation in this
country and um
you know in on in all honesty look like
with how polarized we are
you know maybe diffuse some of that by
saying you know this part of the country
is more
progressive on economic and civil issues
and this and civil liberties issues and
this part of the country's more
um conservative you know maybe a way to
do to to
resolve that discrepancy is allow them
to kind of
go their own way a little bit in terms
of their um
policymaking yeah and as we've seen with
coronavirus there's nothing to stop
a group of states from saying we're
going to work together and just
basically have the same policies
on on this set of issues or that set of
issues so i think legally it's also far
cleaner than some of the other things
that are proposed
all right t from the north shore i
appreciate the phone call
um that is going to do it for live calls
today
let's go to a break and we'll be back
right after this with more friday show